una evacuación obligatoria ordenada por
el presidente ucraniano el sábado por la
noche molodímir selensky pidió a los que
viven en la región de doniesc que se
vayan lo antes posible
hay cientos de miles de personas decenas
de miles de niños mucha gente se niega a
marcharse pero realmente Hay que hacerlo
todavía hay que tomar esta decisión de
todas formas créanme y cuanto antes se
haga cuanta más gente abandone ahora la
región de donieetsk menos gente tendrá
el ejército ruso para matar escaparme
en el dumbas donde se reportan los
combates más intensos viven todavía
cientos de personas
el llamado la evacuación se produjo un
día después de que se bombardeara una
cárcel en la que se encontraban
prisioneros de guerra ucranianos en el
ética controlada por Rusia lo que
provocó la muerte de decenas de personas
estas imágenes de satélite muestran la
prisión que fue objetivo antes y después
del ataque tanto los funcionarios
ucranianos como los rusos se han culpado
mutuamente del incidente el ejército
ucraniano negó las acusaciones de haber
atacado la prisión y a su vez acusó a
Rusia de bombardear olenifka para
encubrir las supuestas torturas y
ejecuciones de los prisioneros
ucranianos allí recluidos